hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the semi-finals of
the mr dodgy invitational of the
prestigious one nonetheless 2.0 it's
daniel dubo versus anishigiri and this
is one of the games that was played it
was an extremely tight match
and uh well let's let's just check it
out uh so daniel has the white pieces
and he opens with
d4 uh we have knight to f6 by an each c
for g6 knight to c3 and the d5 we have
the groomfield defense
and they go for the for the true well
i don't know if if it's called the
traditional line but it's the most often
played line so captures characters e4
knight captures b captures and now
bishop to g7 so this is uh
pretty much standard uh we have knight
to f3 and now
c5 striking in the center uh we have
bishop to b5
check knight to c6 and now rook to b1 so
nothing new here this has all been
played before
uh we have castles by anish and now d5
attacking this knight here
and now there are uh some moves that you
can play here some moves that you can't
knight to e5 is of course an option you
can just put the knight on e5 but anish
chooses
the a6 movie and it's a it's a very
tricky move because it allows uh
white to make a mistake and uh well
i i wouldn't call it a mistake but it's
not uh
as precise that uh that he could have
played
so here he played bishop to d3 and uh
often the bishop is more active on e2
than on d3 and this is also one such
case he played bishop to d3
but this allows anish this very nice
bishop captures on c3 bishop to d2
and now bishop backed the g7 leaving his
uh
uh knight here on pre uh as the bishop
on d3 would also be captured and here if
you
do captures captures you don't really
get anything a white king will be stuck
in the center of the board
and it's uh it's a pretty bad position
uh for
uh for white even if you go something
like characters here it doesn't really
matter queen captures with
check and you will always be able to
recollect this pawn so
it's uh it's a really bad position you
can't even block with queen to e2
because the rook can be one false
so it would just be a total annihilation
so after
bishop to g7 we have castles and now uh
geary just continues to strike on the
queen side with b5
and if you look at the position now uh
yes you can still capture this
don't really do anything black still
captures the bishop on d3
but it's only move 13 and anish already
has a past
c pawn uh that you know a few more moves
and you can start pushing it
uh pushing it uh forward so here bishop
to e3
uh now the bishop is defended and you
have to do something about your knight
hanging on c6 so knight to d4
uh we have knight captures c captures
you could also play bishop captures then
maybe you can
uh pushed upon uh on the c file uh but
gary prefers c
captures on d4 this already uh moves the
pawn one step further so it's now on d4
and it's nicely protected by the dark
square bishop and also opens up the c
file so bishop to g5 and
now comes h6 and here uh giri will
try and make this light uh white's dark
square bishop completely useless
g5 bishop to g3 and now e5
and now this bishop really doesn't have
a bright future so
you might as well free it immediately by
playing the captures on e6 alpha
which uh daniel does so the characters
with bishop captures
and now as black has a two-to-one
advantage on the queen side
uh do both strikes with a4 and
you don't really want to capture them
queen captures and that's uh
not not something you're looking forward
to uh you cannot advance the pawn
nothing is defending it
so here bishop to c4 this is strongest
and this keeps
black's advantage alive so here a
captures with eight captures and
now uh uh here's a very interesting
position
uh because you you really don't want to
capture this if you capture them be
captures then black has to connect
past pawns and that's in no way to enjoy
a chess game
so here there are some moves that are
good like rook to c1 but
there are some uh that are not as good
like
queen to e2 that do both played so here
feel free to pause the video and try to
take advantage of this queen to e2 move
while i give you a couple of second
seconds try and find the move that gear
replayed
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding this
not so easy to find move and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's
rook to a2 grabbing a lot of uh
space with this rook here uh where it
comes with tempo as the queen is under
attack and now you have to waste the
move with white
and then it's again black with uh well
with a very forcing move so here
uh then you'll play the queen back to d1
and now rook to
a3 now threatening to win the bishop
here and there really isn't a good
square for your bishop
for example if you just move the bishop
we can play d3 we attack the bishop and
after you move it somewhere we can play
d2 attack the rook here
with a nice discovery also d1 square is
covered so you can't really move the
rook and
black just wins the game so here uh
bishop
has to be captured daniel captures it we
have b captures now gear
with the two connected past pawns and
rook to b4 he goes after the c4 pawn
now we have rook to c3 at defending the
c for pawn
and now queen to a4 dubo adds another
attacker to the c4 pawn
and giri adds another defender and at
some point when
you know the moment is just right he
will start pushing those past pawns
so we have bishop to d6 attacking the
rook here
and uh well the the there is no time to
waste uh here uh geary just
starts pushing those past pawns and he
starts uh with d3
uh so what do you do here you could
capture the rook or you could try
something else
not capturing the rook might not be the
will
if black offered it and you really don't
have a better move
you might as well capture it you don't
have to do it the bishop is still a very
good
defending piece you could always play
something like e5
uh the bishop will be very nicely placed
on d6 also it keeps an eye on the b6
where so rook the b8 in some lines also
might be a possibility
uh but he grabs it right away with
bishop captures and
rook to b5 now as the rook was under
attack on b4
and now uh as the bishop covers all of
these squares
rook to a3 so rook to a3 now the queen
has to move
queen back to d1 and now c3
as time is of the essence anish
sacrifices the d3 pawn and now the c2
pawn will be extremely strong
so queen captures we have c2 and now
queen to d2
both the rook and the queen guard the
queening square now but now comes queen
to c4
extremely strong attacking the rook here
and what do you play here well here
rook the b8 was played but now as the
title suggests
find out if you are cool pause the video
and try to find the coolest winning move
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding
rook to c3 because this is also winning
uh or rook to d3 but if you found queen
captures on f1 which is the coolest move
then
really congratulations so queen captures
on f1
that's the good stuff we temporarily
sacrifice the queen
only one good move for white king cap
not good only one move for white
available uh and now of course rook to
a1 with
check now adding a defender to the
queening square king the e2
and now c1 queen and now black is just
up a bishop there's really not much you
can do here rook to d8 was played
trying to hold on to this because okay
you are up a pawn so maybe you can you
know grab a draw it's a blitz game with
no seconds increments so maybe it's
possible
but anish finds the quickest way to
victory queen f1 check
king to e3 rook to a3 check we have king
to d4
and here queen to b5 and he was in this
position uh on
38 that daniel dubo resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
uh they still both had over a minute on
the clock but it doesn't really matter
the rook completely cuts off the white
king from the
from going down the the queen is uh i
mean nicely placed here controlling all
of these squares
there's really nothing to do bishop to
g7 check is coming and that's it
uh one one thing you could try for
example rook to d5
still you could go queen b6 check and
now it doesn't really matter
let's say king e5 bishop g7 check king
of five and now we can just deliver
checkmate with queen to e6 so all of the
lines are winning for black
doesn't really matter so yeah after
queen to b5 uh dubo resigned and another
great victory for aneesh giri
and this was a really tough fought match
uh giri defeated
duba with a result of seven to five so
it was i think
dubois started by winning then gear he
fought back then gary started leading
and it was a really really crazy match
uh so giri is going to the finals of the
prestigious mr dodgy invitational 2.0
uh and his opponent uh is uh jabal badur
uh badurja bhava as he defeated
vidit uh with with a score of six and a
half to four and a half
also a hard fought match uh so
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it and that uh you found the coolest
move to win
uh i would like to thank david jeffrey
cook sam console of
kevin hawkins and austin del rio for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh
probably with the finals of the mr dodgy
invitational checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday